l' incendie s'est déclaré un peu avant
10 heures dans ce parking en sous-sol
lieu de stockage pour la fourrière
municipale un seul foyer mais une fumée
âcre difficilement respirable crachés
par de nombreuses bouches d'évacuation
un incendie difficile à maîtriser pour
les pompiers et les hommes progressent
progresse à tâtons
donc c'est à la fois difficile pour
avancer et aussi pour prévoir une une
sortie de secours en cas de difficultés
ces fumées sont très toxiques
il ya bien entendu des risques
d'explosion
notamment des réservoirs de carburant la
fourrière est situé juste en dessous
d'un supermarché très vite évacuée
aucune victime mais pour les salariés le
magasin est inexploitable magasin tout à
fumer et rentrer dans le magasin il ya
plus on voit plus rien il ya tout et
futurs en fait ouais l'origine
criminelle de l'incendié a été confirmée
très rapidement par les enquêteurs
quatre voitures brûlées au départ mais
il y en a sans doute beaucoup plus d il
ya beaucoup de verges pour l'instant le
feu a été mis volontairement à bord des
voitures la fourrière c'est tout moi je
peux pas vous en dire plus je suis comme
fou je viens je viens d'arriver
il ya une voiture c'est qu'ils aient une
deux ou trois voitures qui sont en feu
le feu était allumé intentionnellement
ça je crois qu'on peut le peut le dire
en ce jour de préparation de fait les
habitants étaient nombreux à faire leurs
courses tous pris désormais dans cette
fumée épaisse à midi l'incendié n'était
toujours pas éteint